Quand t'es gamin, il y a une période où tu commences
à comprendre les choses qui t'entourent
et, en même temps,
tu ne comprends pas tout non plus.
Quand j'étais petit, je pensais que
tout ce qu'on voyait dans les films, c'était vrai.
Tout était vrai.
Fais tes adieux !
Coupez
C'est pas "Fais tes adieux !"
mais "Fais ta prière !"
Ah j'ai... Ah désolé !
On la refait, acteur suivant,
virez-moi le cadavre !
Et action !
Fais tes adieux !
Coupez !
Ah merde !
Ah, j'ai encore...
J'suis désolé ! J'suis désolé !
En plus, avec cette...
La boulette ! La boulette !
Quand j'étais petit,
je croyais que si je louchais et qu'il y avait du vent,
je pouvais rester bloqué comme ça
toute ma vie.
C'est ce qu'on m'avait raconté,
du coup, j'y ai cru.
Eh Hubert, Hubert, t'as vu ?
J'arrive à louch... !
(Vent)
Oh non, oh non !
J'vais rester comme ça toute ma vie !
Bon, on fait quoi du coup ?
On va en boîte ?
J'ai envie de draguer des minettes !
Quand j'étais petit,
je croyais que le sel provenait des baleines,
à cause du sel "La Baleine".
Voilà.
Quand j'étais petit, je regardais les publicités
pour les serviettes hygiéniques à la télé,
et je comprenais pas à quoi ça servait.
Et quand je demandais à ma mère,
elle me répondait :
C'est un truc de filles.
Tu comprendras quand tu seras plus grand.
Alors, du coup,
je croyais que...
(Cyprien)
- Mais, maman,
qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
- Non, Cyprien,
ne regarde pas !
...les filles versaient du liquide bleu
sur des serviettes hygiéniques en secret.
- Oh, il m'a vu verser le liquide bleu !
Sors de là ! Sors de là !
Sors de là !
Oh, ma vie est foutue !
C'est foutu !
Même chose pour les tampons.
Je comprenais pas l'utilité
C'est très, très pratique !
Euh oui, je dors beaucoup mieux la nuit !
Non, vraiment, c'est un régal !
J'insiste, c'est très bien !
Très bonne idée, les filles !
Quand j'étais petit, on m'a raconté que
si je faisais pipi dans la piscine municipale,
mon pipi, il allait devenir
d'une couleur, genre rouge ou bleu.
Tout le monde le verrait.
Mais c'est absolument pas vrai !
Tu peux pisser dans la piscine,
personne le verra !
Ce message est approuvé par
l'association des gens dégueulasses.
Quand j'étais petit, je pensais que
quand je jouais à la Super Nintendo contre l'ordinateur,
en fait, je jouais contre quelqu'un,
ailleurs, qui était payé pour ça.
(jingle Super Nintendo)
C'est l'heure de la pause déj' !
Ok, j'arrive, c'est bon, je...
Ah non, ah non, non,
le petit Cyprien veut refaire une partie.
Quand j'étais petit, je croyais que l'animateur de
"Questions pour un Champion"
jouait aussi dans "Batman".
- Top ! À l'âge de six ans, je regarde tous les jours
"Questions pour un Champion"
dans l'espoir de voir Batman à la place du présentateur,
je suis, je suis, je suis...
- Complètement stupide !
- Bonne réponse !
Je suis complètement stupide !
Quand j'étais petit,
je pensais que, avant, il y a très longtemps,
la vie était en noir et blanc.
Ça voudrait donc dire que,
à une époque,
les gens auraient vécu
le passage à la couleur.
Pas mal.
- Sympa, ton t-shirt gris !
- Ah merci !
Ben, j'ai failli le prendre en gris clair
mais je l'ai pris en gris moyen final...
Oh mon Dieu !
C'est quoi, ça ?!
- Quoi ?
Qu'est-ce que...?
Aaah ! Oh mon Dieu !
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?!
C'est quoi ce truc ?!
Ah !
- Ah ! Ah ! Non !
- Ah ! Je veux pas mourir !
- Ah ! Non !
Pourquoi moi ?!
-Enlevez-moi ça !
AAAAAAAH !!!
Conclusion : quand j'étais petit,
j'étais vraiment très con !
Oh, le con !
Ah, j'étais teubé.
Ah oui, au fait,
quand j'étais petit, je ressemblais à ça...
Et toi, tu croyais à quoi
quand t'étais petit ?
Hein ?
Allez, dis-moi tout !
Sous-titrage : TeamSubtitle ET Kenzo et Jojo78
- Quelle mer fermée de l'Asie Occidentale est bordée par la Jordanie et par Israël ?
- C'est la Mer Noire.
- Non. Quelle mer, faisant partie de l'océan Arctique, borde la Sibérie ?
- C'est la Mer Noire ? La Mer...
- Quelle mer, située entre l'Arabie et l'Afrique, est reliée à la Méditerranée par le Canal de Suez ?
- C'est la Mer Noire.
- Non, là elle est rouge celle là.  Au bord de quelle mer est située la station balnéaire de Yalta ?
OUI !